hello everybody my name is naya and
i'm the black female engineer and today
we are going to be talking about
the five main tips to help you get
through
the technical interview and overall get
you
that job because technical interviews to
this day they are
the thing i hate the most part like the
worst part of the recruitment process
for me
but with these five tips you can
definitely step up
your tech interview game and keep in
mind
these are more unconventional tips that
people really
don't talk about it took me going
through the tech interview process
for a couple of times for me to really
see what these interviewers
want to see and so that is this right
here and so
let's get to it so tip
number one the first thing you need to
do when you get that coding question
from your interviewer is express to them
that you know how important this
question
is and so what do i mean by this when
you get a certain coding question
from an interviewer especially if this
is your second or third
interview for that company
likely that question has some relation
to the work
that company actually does and so let's
say you're interviewing for like six
flags or disney
the interview question you get could be
something related to
their amusement parks that's actually
the situation i had where the company i
was interviewing for
had worked in the realm of parks in some
of their business and the question i had
had to do with the with the um amusement
parks
and the wait times and organizing you
know
data and all of this and so the first
thing you do
or the first thing i did was say
thank you for bringing up this problem i
understand that because
we are in a panoramic you know
parallelogram panera bread
that the issue of organizing amusement
parks in a certain way is very very
important
for the functionality of the business
but also making sure that people
are still safe while also having fun and
so
i'm really excited to dive in with this
question
period boom right there the interviewer
is like
okay okay i see what you did there
you showed that you care
about our business and you see
what we do and what we deal with every
single day and that's important because
y'all when you are going through a
technical interview
what they're really trying to see and
this is like a secret
so like they're not really looking
to see if you'll answer the problem i
mean
sure if you answer that's great but
they're seeing what kind of engineer
are you are you a person who
just takes a problem and just puts out
answers like a machine
or are you a person who is able to think
beyond
the problem and provide real solutions
that are robust
and are will be able to withstand the
test of time
and really is brought because of your
true
understanding of what we're dealing with
they're trying to see what type of
engineer you are and so by spitting back
the problem at them and sharing why
you know it's important it shows them
that you
care about the work they do and they
want people who care
okay so you just told them why
the problem is important now the next
thing
you do is inspect your
inputs so this is specific with
javascript because that's really the
language i'm most proficient in in terms
of
coding interviews and so
with javascript you know hackerings or
you know
coding interviews and all of this you're
given some type of
starting point they say okay here's an
array of
10 amusement parks now do this this or
solve the problem with this is this
whatever they give you to start
manipulating or to use to solve the
problem
before you even solve the problem look
at what they give you
is it in a way is it structured in a way
that is efficient that actually
works for you or will just make things
harder in the long run
and so one easy way to spot this is
do they give you just a lot of strings
that is a good way of being of telling
that this is not the most efficient this
can be now
for beginners what's a string a string
is really just text
that's the data structure it's words or
numbers but
in wrapped in quotations and in
javascript it's very difficult
to well maybe not very difficult but
it's
more difficult than it should be to
manipulate strings and if you're trying
to manipulate strings to solve
you know a problem or a certain you know
organizing of things that's going to be
pretty what's the word like
just inefficient and will just make you
go through
a bunch of hoopla and hurdles for
for not a good cause and so the first
thing you would do in the situation
is convert those strings to something
else and so if
is there a number in the string make
sure you take it out of a string and
make sure it's a number because for
example
you can't multiply strings together you
can't add strings together so if it's a
one
in quotes you can't use that to like do
any math
but by taking it out of those quotes you
can now
do math on it you can now add it to
certain data structures in ways that you
couldn't have done with a string
and that's one very good way to tell are
these inputs that they're giving me
are they efficient are they
the best they can be or can i change
them and so
if you see this and the answer is
actually
i could work better with this if it was
in this form first thing you do
make it that form make the first
function
you create be a function to alter
that given input now technically it's
not directly solving the problem at hand
but again it goes back to what type of
engineer are you
are you the type of engineer to just
take what you've been given
and try the best you can with it even
though you know
it's inefficient and you know it's not
the best it could be
or are you the type of engineer who
identifies that there is a certain
problem with what you've been given and
the first thing you'll do
is make sure you resolve that before
going to your next steps what
type of engineer art that is always
the number one thing we need to get back
to and we need to show them that you're
an engineer
who thinks ahead and who can take a step
back
to look at the scenery to see things
around
before just jumping into a problem so my
next tip
tip number three you get this you know
problem and everything they give you
your inputs and they say
run with it what is the answer how do
you solve this problem if it's a longer
type
problem don't just create one
function and just be doing all your
steps in that function and just be
typing away
and end with this like 50 lines of code
all in one function
no break up the problem if there are
multiple steps to
solving the problem break it up and
likely unless
the question is what's one plus one
there are multiple steps to the problem
a
rule of thumb with javascript
is make sure your functions aren't
more than five to seven lines long
and that still applies in coding
interviews because again now i'm going
to say this
until you just hear it everywhere
what type of engineer are you are you
the type of engineer
who just provides and produces just
blocks of code
or are you the engineer who can make
sure things are
readable and are efficient and are
easily transferable between teams
because by making sure your functions
are each just five to seven lines long
it shows that you are the latter which
is what we
want as a company that's what i would
want as a company but you know what
what do i know i just have a job but
but no seriously y'all and
i will say this it's hard to do
when there is a pair of eyes on you or
if it's even worse where
there's multiple people in your tech
interview just
looking at you or if you're working in
hackery and there's just
the timer just right in front of you
it's hard to remember to take a step
back and solve a problem holistically
rather than just beating out lines of
code i it's hard to do but
i understand that but you need to
remember
the goal is not to solve the problem
i know i know it's wild that i'm saying
this
the goal is not to solve the problem is
to show them
what type of engineer are
you okay now before getting to tip
number four i'm gonna remind y'all to
click that subscribe button
and click the like button if if you
like what you're hearing if there's one
tip in here that you didn't think before
that you think can help
please click that like button and
subscribe if you've liked my content i
really
want this community to grow and i love
how much it has so far so thank you all
and now let's get to tip number four
tip number four after you have solved
the problem
or because let's you know let's be
honest we don't always solve the problem
like
i surely don't after we're done
all we can you know to get through
the problem finish it off by saying
what the next steps for the engineering
team would be
if you had gotten this problem you know
at your desk
at work and now it's time to hand it off
what is the next type because odds are
this project this problem it doesn't end
with you your manager when you you know
get that dream job
they're not going to approach your desk
and be like hey can you solve this
problem and then
you give them something they're like
cool they put a stamp on it and send it
off like no
it doesn't end with you there are more
people in the chain
that this is going to go to and your the
way you go about this problem the way
your team goes about this problem likely
has an effect
on the company's next steps and so think
about what those next steps would be
and so let's go back to the amusement
park problem okay
so we just went through that the best we
could we solved it we didn't solve it
we did the best we could now finish it
off by saying
so really the next steps would be for
the engineering team to come together
with a business team and be able to
understand what wait times are longer
than others which rides experience more
wait times more popularity
and find ways to reorganize the park or
reorganize certain um business times to
make sure people do stay safe while also
making sure the park is functioning
at mass efficiency this may include
adding new park rides or
re-um or rearranging certain rides
certain wait times or even structuring a
line in a certain way to make sure that
people um are staying at that six feet
apart range to limit
exposure boom
there we go now think about
what that interview must be thinking
like
okay not only did you go through the
problem
with x y and z but
you also shed insight onto
what we as a company should do next that
shows
again that you would be the type of
worker that
thinks ahead and are and care
more about the larger picture
not just what your job is but how
your job affects his job and his
manager's job and his manager's job
that shows that you also have leadership
qualities by being able to
think in this holistic sense and that
is a type of employee companies want
and now finally tip number five to
really
show this company that you are the
person for the job
is to make sure that when you are going
through the coding through the analysis
and typing things out make sure you
don't
get too abstract with your function
names with
your variable names make sure things are
kept
very very readable and easy to follow so
instead of saying something
like let x equal two plus two say
something like
let total rides equal two plus two
by changing that x to a more descriptive
name then the teams because again we're
thinking about if we have the job we're
not thinking about just the
coding interview right now then the team
who
later has this project or is later
inspecting our code
can now follow along
way better and way faster than if it
just says
x because if it just says x now the team
has to scroll through all the code and
find the origin of x
and see what it was originally assigned
to and that takes time y'all like that
is
time that people don't have up in these
like no we don't want
that we want to make sure that we are
keeping our code as efficient as
possible
as readable as possible to make sure
that when we do hand it off
that person spends as little time as
possible understanding
what we wrote i and i know you are gonna
bite my head off for saying this but
we are showing them the type of engineer
we will be
will we be the difficult engineer in the
office because
kathy over here just constantly puts
the most abstract obscure
variable names and so constantly makes
my job harder
or is she a person who thinks about
the person that's going to see this next
and make sure that things are
super readable and super easy to follow
because coding
can be hard enough in its own i don't
need to
be bringing my head around the table
because
i can't figure out where x is and what x
was that's not something we want and
that's not
an employee we want to in our team
someone who makes the job harder for
people
no that's not what we want so this is
such an easy way to show your
interviewer that
you can make things as simple as
possible for the people around you so
let me give you all
of a story time now that we went through
those five tips
my interview so i had an interview with
a company that
was my dream company
i get all the way to the third round and
it was um
i had to set up you know a technical
solution and everything for the coding
problem
i get my score back from hack because it
was administered through hacker rank i
get my score back from hacker rank
y'all i got
a 0 out of 75
and i am not lying to you just to like
get views or like i am not lying to you
i got a 0
out of 75. i actually did a talk about
it um
in women who code i spoke with them
on how to fail the javascript hacker
rank and still get the job
yes this is that story i got a 0 75
but because of the five things i laid
out for you today
because of those things i showed them
that i am the type of engineer
they want and i got a job offer
20 minutes after my interview
and so i am i swear by these tips
so keep in mind y'all you can be the
best engineer out there
but you can still get a question that
just throws you for a loop
and you get a score that you
don't want or you get frazzled or you
like go into this spin
of not knowing how to solve it it's okay
to not know how to solve
a problem i'm serious like i'm really
serious y'all it is
okay to not know how to solve it and
it's okay to not
solve it in totality to not come up with
that exact answer
because what a company is seeing or
wants to see
is what type of engineer are
you and what type of engineer would you
be
in this company so keep that
in mind so no thank you so much for
getting through this with me i'm so
excited to just
like i said see this community grow so
please click that subscribe button
and i will see you all very very soon
bye y'all